what is deep learning
is there a way you'd like to think of it
that is different than like a generic
textbook definition
the thing that i hinted just a second
ago is maybe the
closest to how i'm thinking these days
about them deep learning
so
now the statement is
neural networks can represent some
programs
uh seems that various modules that we
are actually adding up to are like a you
know we we want networks to be deep
because we we want multiple steps of the
computation
and uh
and deep learning provides the way to
represent space of programs which is
searchable and it's searchable with a
stochastic gradient descent so we have
an algorithm to search over
a humongous number of programs and
gradient descent kind of bubbles up the
things that are uh tend to give correct
answers so
a neural network
with the with fixed weights
that's optimized do you think of that as
a single program um so there is a work
by christopher olach where he
so he works on interpretability of
neural networks and he was able to uh
to identify inside of the neural network
for instance a detector of a wheel for a
car or the detector of a mask for a car
and then he was able to separate them
out and assemble them uh together using
a simple program uh for the detector for
a car detector that's like uh if you
think of traditionally defined programs
that's like a function within a program
that this particular neural network was
able to find and you can
tear that out just like you can copy and
paste from stack overflow
that
so uh any program is a composition of
smaller programs
yeah i mean the nice thing about the
neural networks is that it allows the
things to be more fuzzy than in case of
programs
in case of programs you have this like a
branching this way or that way and the
neural networks they they have an easier
way to
to be somewhere in between or to share
things
what to use the most beautiful or
surprising idea in deep learning and the
utilization of these neural networks
which by the way for people who are not
familiar
neural networks is a bunch of uh
what would you say it's inspired by the
human brain there's neurons there's
connection between those neurons there's
inputs and there's outputs and there's
millions or billions of those neurons
and the learning
happens
uh by adjusting the weights on the edges
that connect these neurons thank you for
giving definition that
i supposed to do it but i guess you have
enough empathy to listeners to actually
know that
that might be useful no that's like
so i'm asking plato of like what is the
meaning of life he's not going to answer
you're being philosophical and deep and
quite profound talking about the space
of programs which is just very
interesting but also for people just not
familiar with the hell we're talking
about when we talk about deep learning
anyway sorry what is the most beautiful
or surprising idea to you in in
in all the time you've worked at deep
learning and you worked on a lot of
fascinating projects
applications of neural networks
it doesn't have to be big and profound
it can be a cool trick yeah i mean i'm
thinking about the trick but like
it's still amusing to me that it works
at all yeah that let's say that the
extremely simple algorithm stochastic
gradient descent which is something that
i would be able you know to derive on
the piece of paper to high school
student
uh when put at the
ins at the scale of you know thousands
of machines actually
can create
the
behaviors we which we called kind of
human-like behaviors
so in general
any application of stochastic gradient
descent to neural networks is
is amazing to you so that
or is there a particular application in
natural language
reinforcement learning
and also would you attribute
that success to is it just scale
what profound insight can we take from
the fact that
the thing works for gigantic
uh sets of variables
i mean the interesting thing is these
algorithms they were
invented
decades ago and
people actually
gave up on the idea yeah and
you know back then they thought that we
need profoundly different algorithms and
they spent a lot of cycles on very
different algorithms and i believe that
you know we have seen that various
various innovations that say like
transformer or or dropout or so they can
you know pass the help but it's also
remarkable to me that this algorithm
from 60s or so
or i mean you can even say that the
gradient descent was invented by life
needs in i guess 18th century or so that
actually is the core of learning
in the past people are
it's almost like a out of the maybe an
ego people are saying that it cannot be
the case that such a simple algorithm is
there you know
uh could solve complicated problems
so they were in search for the
other algorithms and as i'm saying like
i believe that actually we are in the
game where there is there are actually
frankly three levels there is compute
there are algorithms and there is data
and
if we want to build intelligent systems
we have to pull all three levers
and they are actually multiplicative
and it's also interesting so you ask is
it only compute
people internally they did the studies
to determine how much gains they were
coming from different levels and so far
we have seen that more gains came from
compute than algorithms but also we are
in the world that in case of compute
there is a kind of you know exponential
increase in funding and at some point
it's impossible to
invest more it's impossible to you know
invest 10 trillion dollars because we
are speaking about the
let's say
all taxes in
u.s but you're talking about money there
could be innovation
in the compute that's that's true as
well
you